outside the Aligarh Muslim University in
India's northern state of Uttar Pradesh
there is a constant police presence on
Monday University authorities here
declared a holiday in the middle of
exams on Sunday police stormed the
campus grounds students were protesting
against the controversial new
citizenship law that allows religious
minorities from neighboring countries to
apply for Indian citizenship the
legislation specifically excludes
Muslims in any Minister for a mr.
anybody he talks that Muslims are
excluded then naturally it will create
fear among the people I'm professor of
psychology I know the importance of the
fear students say police barged into the
dormitories hit them and vandalize
property the police fired tear gas and
rubber bullets a sweeper told us that
some 30 trucks cleaned up the campus
before 7 a.m.
some students showed us pictures of
their injuries they say the police have
filed cases against them and some of
them are detained and tortured in
custody
dr. Lior fear there was a small bomb
like thing that came towards me when I
picked it up to throw it back it
exploded in my hand other students for a
strip naked beaten and forced to drink
alcohol the students say they still
don't know where some of their friends
are Internet has been cut off in Allegan
most of the students from out of the
city have already been sent back home in
buses the remaining students some of
whom we have talked to say that they
have been warned by the campus
authorities not to talk to media unless
they want to be suspended we reached out
to the campus authorities this is a very
old institution and is having a very
high values ruins are they are they are
allowed to make their voices heard in a
democratic manner in a peaceful manner
there's no question of this that any
student is asked to nor to talk to media
we were not given permission to shoot at
the University we found this small group
of students protesting at the main gate
no complaining that we are protesting in
an undemocratic way we chose this way
you can't make us quiet you can before
long campus authorities along with the
police told us that we could no longer
talk to these students Sabina Shrestha
al-jazeera Luther Pradesh India